JOHANNA WRIGHT: So now
I'm so excited to
introduce Diane Greene.
Diane Greene is the
latest member of
Google's Board of Directors.
She's also a board member
for Intuit and MIT.
Diane is probably most well
known for founding VMware.
VMware went on to define the
visualization industry.
Diane was the CEO of VMware
from 1998 to 2008.
She took the company to $2
billion in revenue, and she
took the company public.
When I heard that I got to be
on the same panel as Diane
Greene, I was flabbergasted,
and so excited.
Despite how intimidating her
resume sounds, Diane Greene is
actually quite approachable.
I heard her speak last year at
a Google event and I went up
and introduced myself
afterwards, and she was very
friendly and nice.
So if you get the opportunity
afterwards, I would encourage
you to shake her hand.
Diane is also a national
champion sailor.
And with that, Diane.
[APPLAUSE]
DIANE GREENE: Thank you
for that introduction.
She went further than
I suggested she go.
So how did I manage to
do these things?
What I thought I would do is
take you on a whirlwind tour
of my life and try and highlight
where I thought I
learned valuable things.
And I grew up sailing,
racing sailboats.
And when you race a boat, first
you have to build a
team, and you have to get your
team all aligned on a single
goal, which is to
win the race.
And then you need your strategy
to win the race.
You have to understand what the
wind's doing, understand
what the currents are doing,
and pay attention to your
competitors.
And if your competitors surprise
you or you get a wind
shift, you have to immediately
react and handle that and
continue winning the race.
And the last thing is the
engineering around sailing.
You have to prepare your boat.
It has to be ready to go fast.
Then you have to tune it while
on the race course to keep
going fast.
And I think that's what
led me to train.
I trained as a mechanical
engineer and
then a naval architect.
I came out to the Bay Area
to San Francisco
for my first job.
And the first thing I was given
to do was analyze some
mooring, a mooring for an
offshore oil platform that was
used for firefighting.
And there was a big Fortran
program that looked like it
was the way to model this.
And so that's when I learned
how to program.
And it was just this incredibly
powerful tool, software.
You could do anything with it.
Got pretty excited about it.
Was not very excited about
sitting inside behind a desk.
I really came to the Bay Area
for the windsurfing.
And so I quit that job and I
moved to Hawaii where I think
I've had perhaps one of my
favorite periods of my life.
I lived sort of in a commune
where we were exploring.
Windsurfing was sort
of an early
microcosm of the tech industry.
We were just inventing
all kinds of things--
new sails, high aspect
sails, new shapes
of boards, new materials.
And all we did was build and
test this equipment every day.
It was really tremendous.
And from there, I went and ran
engineering for Windsurfing
International.
That was the company that had
the patent on the windsurfer,
which also taught me how abused
patents can be, because
they tried to control a very
rapidly expanding industry
with their patents.
I left that.
Well, all this time, I continued
to study software.
I went back up to the Bay Area
and enrolled in a graduate
program in computer science
at UC Berkeley.
Berkeley was a pretty happening
place at that point.
The grad students had a lab
full of brand new Sun
workstations that were based on
this Unix, a relatively new
open operating system.
Richard Stallman, who wrote
the GPL license,
was hanging out there.
I got to see the first graphical
user interface, and
it was just very exciting.
And I knew it's what I
wanted to keep doing.
I did still yearn
for adventure.
I've always really loved
adventure, so I took a brief
interlude and used my computer
skills to be the computer
expert on a marine archaeology
expedition in Sipan where we
excavated a Spanish galleon
and found gold.
And then I came back to the Bay
Area and went to work at a
succession of companies
in the tech industry.
The first one was Sybase, where
I really got hit over
the head with the value of
having engineers across
companies work together.
I made friends with an engineer
at Sun, it turned out
he was a windsurfer, and we
spend a few months windsurfing
and writing software and were
able to get sort of an order
of magnitude performance
increase in the Sybase system
running on Sun.
And I really used that
when I built VMware.
All three companies were quite
an education in how important
it is to embrace change and
always go forward, invest in
the future.
Sybase didn't want to rework
their system to support
symmetric multiprocessing
processing, and that's sort of
why Oracle eclipsed them.
I went to work at Tandem that
had the world's best database
management system, but it ran
on proprietary hardware and
proprietary operating system.
And it was too hard to see the
business model for moving to
commodity open systems, and
they sort of sailed into
oblivion, getting bought by
Compaq and then by HP.
And then I went to work for
SGI, which was a pretty
aggressive tech company at that
point in time and worked
on interactive television,
which was a
really exciting project.
But again, the internet
was happening and it
was starting at SGI.
But instead, the founder of
SGI, Jim Clark, left and
founded Netscape, and
a number of us
left and started companies.
And that's when I finally
just decided
to stick with startups.
And so I did two successive
smaller startups.
They both had great visions.
I would say they maybe
executed too early.
Nice financial outcomes.
The first one was streaming
video over the internet, low
bandwidth, because there
wasn't much bandwidth.
And the second was internet ad
serving, interestingly enough.
At that point I took a little
time off and decided to found
VMware, which was based on some
work my husband was doing
at Stanford around
virtualization.
And there's a few things I can
kind of relate to what we did
at VMware to what I had
already learned.
For instance, Sun Microsystems
introduced these workstations.
People loved these workstations,
and then brought
their servers into
the companies.
And at VMware we used
the same strategy.
We had a workstation software.
People loved our workstation
software, and then when we
came out with the server
product, were pretty
quick to adopt it.
We did amazing.
Our engineers worked with
the hardware vendors.
They worked with the
chip vendors.
storage vendors.
And then we worked with
all of those vendors
to take it to market.
And I'm just a huge believer in
collaboration in the industry.
And it was really effective for
VMware, but it was always
hard to convince other companies
to trust us and
partner with us.
But I think we always won,
jointly, together.
And then the last thing was just
sort of how to adapt, how
to embrace change.
My job changed considerably from
zero to sort of 6,000,
7,000 people the company
was when I left.
And it's just sort of
recognizing, OK, this isn't
working and constantly
sectioning out parts of my job
that I just didn't have time for
anymore and hiring someone
to do those things.
VMware was just a totally fun
adventure, building it with
all those people and seeing
the impact that it had.
And what I would say is, it's
not so important how.
There's just sort of
an infinite number
of ways to do things.
But when you see something that
you're very interested
in, that you think it can have
some real impact, the thing
that's important is to codify
that vision, see that vision,
enjoy the adventure of
building that vision.
And if you do enjoy it, it makes
it fairly easy to be
fearless about it.